le porte-parole de l'association des
musulmans sur saint cyr l'école et
fontenay le fleury est l'invité de cette
édition la fête de l'aïd sera célébrée
demain c'est la grande fête de l'islam
une fête dont on parle beaucoup souvent
mais pas forcément on la connaît on la
connaissait très bien je vous laisse re
préciser ce que représente pour la
communauté musulmane cette grande fête
de l'islam qui l'a aidé à bien la fête
de l'aïd el-kébir c'est la fête c'est
vraiment la grande fête telle qu'on
l'appelle comme ça c'est pas c'est pas
par hasard c'est parce qu'elle
représente le moment deux plus
importants en matière de festivités pour
la communauté musulmane
vous avez deux grandes fêtes c'est la
fête marquant la fin du ramadan qui est
donc l'aïd el fitr qu'on a ainsi libéré
célébré il ya deux mois
et là vous avez la grande fête qui
arrive maintenant qui est le jour qui
est un des jours les plus importants et
parfois même certains pensent que c'est
le jour le plus important pour
symboliser un peu la fête dans la
communauté musulmane
elle correspond à quels événements alors
elle pourrait cependant la commémoration
d'un événement bien particulier qui est
celui du sacrifice d'abraham le
sacrifice d'abraham qui selon la
tradition musulmane n'a pas eu lieu
parce que justement au moment où du a
demandé à brown de mettre fin aux jours
de son fils et ismail et que par la
suite donc l'écran qui l'a vu que
ibrahim
elle est vraiment obéir à son son
commandement à transformer la présence
de 10 miles par un bouc qui la vie à la
place 1 à nyon qui l'a mis à la place de
son fils pour donc dire que il avait
reçu la preuve que ibrahim allait bien
remplir son sens son commandement à
l'est a accepté de devenir un
commandement divin qui lui a été donné
donc pour nous chaque année en souvenir
de cette de cet événement là nous
procéderons à ce que l'on appelle à la
fête du sacrifice c'est aussi un autre
nom de l'aïd el-kébir 2
la grande fête comme on appelle dans
l'afrique de l'est on parle de tabaski
on a une grande communauté africaine ici
en france donc les gens parlent de la
tabaski chez les maghrébins on parle de
l'aïd el-kébir et chez d'autres vous
l'entendez d'une autre façon mais
toujours c'est le même événement qui est
célébrée et marque vraiment un point
culminant de la communauté musulmane est
la problématique cette année dans le
département des yvelines c'est l'absence
d'abattoir depuis plusieurs années déjà
ils ont disparu de ce département des
yvelines une solution temporaire avait
été trouvée du côté des longs cours d
abattoir mobile avait été installée une
solution qui n'existe plus alice je vous
laisse refaire le point justement sur ce
dossier oui tout à fait donc on le
disait un cet abattoir à elancourt
permettait aux familles de
l'agglomération et puis même un petit
peu au-delà parce que c'est vraiment le
département qui est concerné de pouvoir
venir avec son mouton et puis qu'ils
puissent être sacrifié sous les yeux
parce que c'est aussi important que les
familles puissent voir le sacrifice dans
la tradition fait c'est le père de
famille qui qui doit réaliser ce
sacrifice
là avec ce basse cette nouvelle façon de
faire un ce dispositif n'était pas
possible
mais les familles pouvaient quand même
repartir avec leurs moutons sacrifiés
alors nous avons joint par téléphone la
direction départementale de la
protection des personnes qui est en
charge inquiété en charge de toute cette
organisation et qui nous a expliqué
pourquoi
l'abattage clandestin était interdite
pour trois raisons tout d'abord parce
que l'abattoir est un circuit déclaré un
pour la viande qu'on achète
quotidiennement
ensuite parce que les conditions
d'abattage sont armés pour éviter la
souffrance des bêtes
et puis ensuite parce que l'inspection
sanitaire sur les animaux abattus est
obligatoire pour contrôler la salubrité
quelle est votre opinion sur
l'interdiction des abattoirs clandestins
ben le monde opinions et les toute
simple elle est celle que vous venez de
donner là la personne qui vous a
expliqué ça vous avez vraiment relevé
l'écran de raisons pour lesquelles il
faut les interdire l'abattage clandestin
personne n'est pour autant musulmans en
france aujourd'hui ne vous dira s'il est
sain d'esprit ne vous dira qu'il est
pour les abattoirs clandestins personne
parce que pour des risques pour des rues
pour des raisons d'hygiène
on ne peut pas garantir l'hygiène de
c'est à eux qu'on va qu'on voit certains
le prat va sacrifier alors ceux qui le
pratiquent ce sont ceux je ne cherche
pas à les défendre mais peut-être qu'ils
n'ont pas les moyens de pouvoir accéder
à un abattoir normand
entre guillemets c'est à dire dans
lequel toutes ces conditions d'hygiène
et de salubrité serait respecté un coup
aussi les fans absolus board et ceux qui
n'ont pas compris que la condition de
d'hygiène et de salubrité
il est aussi une des conditions dans
lesquelles on doit choisir l'agneau pour
son abattage rituel
alors cet abattoir qui étaient mis en
place sur la commune d'el en cours était
financé donc par les mairies en fait un
de l'agglomération aujourd'hui la mairie
d'elancourt qui dispose encore un du
matériel qui est propriétaire du
matériel ne peut plus assumer ces coûts
de fonctionnement mais en fait n'importe
qui pourrait financer en fait ce
fonctionnement alors est ce que les
communautés musulmanes pourrait prendre
le relais
alors je précise déjà une chose c'est
que je ne parle pas au nom de la
communauté musulmane de des yvelines
même pas des idées alors à plus forte
raison de france je vous donne mon
opinion en tant que musulmans et en tant
que membre d'une association locale
je peux vous dire que effectivement je
crois savoir je crois savoir que c'était
c'est un accord qui avait été passé
entre le cam 78 collectif des
associations musulmanes des yvelines et
donc ces différentes autorités
municipales et autres des différentes
villes je crois savoir que cette année
il n'y en aura pas puisque pour des
raisons financières puisque le
financement n'ayant pas été à qui
personne n'a remplacé qui que ce soit je
crois savoir que le cam et en est en
démarche en ce moment auprès de ces
mairies là pour voir quels sont les
moyens de trouver quelque chose je ne
suis pas très au fait de ce dossier là
comme je vous ai dit parce que je ne
suis pas membre du cam 78 je ne suis pas
au fait des négociations
mais en tant que musulman je peux vous
dire que c'est la catastrophe pour nous
parce que au moment où on arrive à au
jour le plus important pour nous on va
quand accomplir le geste le plus
important que celui du sacrifice ben on
ne pourra pas le faire cette année ni à
fontenay le fleury ni à saint cyr
l'école comme les autres années
d'ailleurs puisqu'on avait été exclu un
peu de ce2 ce2 ce2 cet événement là
parce que les mairies n'ont pas voulu
participer au financement et l'amérique
l'abattoir catésien elle encore
effectivement ne concerne pas l'ensemble
des communes des départements et les
villes qui avaient participé au
financement
donc nous on est encore d'autant plus
touché puisque maintenant on peut même
plus avoir un abattoir mobile à côté
pour pouvoir et pour des raisons x ou y
et va pouvoir réaliser c'est cela
justement comment vous avez vos organes
pour cette année ah bah justement n'y a
pas d'organisation c'est que justement
notre président monsieur marc bouchard a
fait une communication en dix ans la
communauté musulmane
sachez que cette année il n'y aura pas
d'abattoirs mobile et donc c'est chacun
pour soi vous allez célébrer justement
là bas nous allons célébrer cette fête
en disant adieu voilà nous nous aurions
voulu pouvoir donc procéder à l'abattage
rituel mais que ben aujourd'hui les
conditions ne sont pas réunies et donc
nous lançons un appel aux différentes
mairies 1 pour qu'on puisse trouver une
solution rapidement parce que c'est une
déception énorme pour toute la
communauté musulmane française concept
ce communiqué a été fait par notre
président monsieur bouchard je peux vous
garantir qu'on a eu des coups de
téléphone on a eu des gens qui nous ont
arrêtés dans la rue pour se dire mais
exactement ce qu'on venait de me
demander comment allons-nous faire cette
année ah ben je ne sais pas comment
enfin parce que les abattoirs les plus
proches ils sont où un raid à étampes à
dreux et ailleurs est ce qu'il ya un
risque justement de voir se multiplier
ces abattoirs clandestins alors nous
espérons que non mais si jamais c'était
le câble je pense que les autorités qui
n'ont pas voulu ou qui n'ont pas pu je
n'en sais rien je vous ai dis encore une
fois je suis moi au courant de ce
dossier je ne maîtrise pas de a à z et
je peux pas vous dire ce qu'il en est
exactement mais je pense que les
autorités qui n'ont pas pu participer au
financement de cet abattoir mobile on
vend une responsabilité énorme
il faudra se tourner vers ces autorités
la plus grosse quand vous le message que
vous véhiculez calme et sa célébration
qui sont membres de notre association
car il ne faut pas qu'il y ait
d'abattage clandestin
il ne faut pas qu'il y ait davantage
clandestins ça c'est la position de
notre association nous nous voulons que
les choses se passent aux grands aux
grands bureaux mais aussi de tout le
monde pour que tout le monde puisse dire
voilà ce sont des sacrifices rituels qui
se passe dans des conditions qui sont
garanties par la république on va
écouter quelques témoignages justement
quelques témoignages divine mois de
musulmans que nous avons rencontrés
aujourd'hui avec cette question comment
allez vous célébrer l'aïd cette année
alors qu'il n'y a pas de battoir mobile
dans le département sur la chaîne chose
c'est qu'on va acheter un peu de viande
chez le boucher
mais c'est tout puisqu'on peut plus tu
es comme d'habitude maintenant
on va au boucher c'est la seule solution
doit on était obligé voir comme on dit
la boucherie y lisons des moyens pour
pour les fermer tôt mais quand moi je
préfère chez la boucherie simplement en
cherchant son salut va voir si possible
et à quelque part dans les fermes aussi
possible alors on va essayer d'aller à
avoir un peu à dreux pour quelques uns
charte et voir si c'est possible sinon
on s'abstient on n'y peut rien c'est mon
mari qui s'en occupe je pense qu'il va
lâcher tout près près normalement le
vrai hit faut l'acheter vivant le bouton
fait d'égorger après mais en france
alors c'est plus possible
on va essayer d'aller comme les autres
années donc
normalement et puis on va chez de la
viande dans les boucheries musulmanes
plusieurs pistes évoquées acheter la
viande dans les boucheries musulmanes ou
alors ne pas donc faire le sacrifice
comme vous le disiez parce que pas
d'abattoirs clandestins que pensez-vous
de l'alternative du marché au vif qui a
été mis en place at et ce en cours le
principe un jeune âge explique ses
terres que les familles viennent choisir
leurs moutons la veille du jour de l'aïd
ensuite pendant la nuit les bêtes sont
emmenés dans un abattoir en normandie
puis rapatrié à thé sancourt ensuite
chaque famille récupère son animal
aujourd'hui la communauté musulmane qui
n'est pas en mesure de procéder à
l'abattage rituel dans des conditions
qui sont les victimes
la révision de musulmanes le monsieur
vous disiez tout à l'heure mais on n'a
pas le choix et c'est exactement ça les
gens n'ont pas le choix mais je ne pense
pas que parce que les gens n'ont pas le
choix il faut qu'il soit face à une
solution qui s'impose à eux mais c'est
plutôt de chercher des voies et moyens
de pouvoir justement trouver des
solution qui satisfasse tout le monde
c'est au vif au possible et un vrai
succès je n'en sais rien je ne peux pas
vous le dire mais je sais qu'aujourd'hui
en tout cas pour ce qui concerne la
communauté musulmane de fontenay le
fleury et de saint-cyr-l'ecole que moi
je connais personnellement assez bien
les gens sont complètement abattu et ça
m'étonnerait qu'il y en ait beaucoup
qu'ils aient des lectrices dirige là
parce que les gens sont complètement
déçu et abattu il faut vraiment qu'on
trouve une solution
ça ne peut pas durer merci à 10 pour ces
précisions vous restez bien sur ce
plateau puisque dans quelques instants
nous parlons économie avec votre envie
tête de la chronique de l'écho le
président du medef soixante dix huit
mois mais d'où le 22ème juste vous faire
réagir pour conclure cet entretien sur
un autre sujet qui concerne directement
votre association la communauté
musulmane de saint céré de fontenay
c'est la création éventuellement d'une
mosquée il n'y a pas de mosquée sur ce
secteur vous l'a demandé depuis
plusieurs années et demain à l'issue de
la prière vous devriez recevoir les
maires des deux communes saint cyr
l'école et fontenay vous les avez invité
en tout cas oui c'est un moment de
partage et chaque année si l'occasion
pour nous de remercier les autorités
municipales des deux villes même qu'on
aurait monsieur
le maire de saint cyr lecture devant
monsieur de 20 bernard dodin il en
voudra si je plisse si vous l'avez
réalise pas une espèce surtout que c'est
quelqu'un que je connais personnellement
donc il m'en voudras ne m'en veut passer
l'émotion
bernadette laclais donc je pense que oui
c'est un moment où on partage vraiment
le bonheur de la fête et ce moment de
fête on ne vous parle pas c'est tout
simplement entre nous entre dans la
communauté musulmane
on veut que ce soit aussi au moment où
on accueille les autorités pour le
remercier parce que pendant le ramadan
ce sont des gens qui font beaucoup de
choses pour la communauté musulmane et
donc pour le remercier aussi pour leur
rappeler un peu notre problématique c
est celle d'un lieu de culte sur une des
deux villes au moins parce que là c'est
justement parce que la demande dure
depuis plusieurs années où en est ce
dossier en service dans ce cas ça fait
plus de choses que nous courons après
les autorités municipales des deux
villes un feu l'ancien maire de fontenay
monsieur lasserre avec une certification
pendant des années avec nous aujourd'hui
ici avec madame connor que je salue au
passage qui est d'un formidable d'un
courage extraordinaire que je respecte
pour ses valeurs républicaines qu'elle
qu'elle démontre tous les jours parce
que j'ai le plaisir de la côtoyer un
certain brillant et je m'en fous je
m'aperçois à chaque fois mais ces
valeurs républicaines qu'elle qu'elle
devrait présenter et le courage qu'elle
prend aujourd'hui une disons que on a
une trace un lieu qui pourrait convenir
à peu près à l'édification de ce lieu de
culte qui englobera je ne précise pas
seulement lieu de prière mais également
un lieu social parce qu'il durera et à
des activités aussi bien scolaire que
social dans ce dieu là donc ça c'est
essentiel parce que notre association
c'est l'association socioculturelle
elle n'est pas que une association
cultuelle est donc une proposition a été
faite au maire de saint cyr l'école
puisque le lieu qui a été identifié une
partie de ce territoire est sur le
domaine de la mairie de
de fargniers le fleury et l'autre pas et
l'autre partie sur celle de saint cyr ça
nécessite pour que le lieu de culte
puissent être établies et édifié sur ce
temps le voilà qu'il y ait une révision
du plu de saint cyr l'école
une lettre a été envoyée signé par
madame connor et une lettre que nous
avons envoyé des lettres que nous avons
ri des tonnes de lettres nous avons
envoyé appelons monsieur de bain à faire
une révision du pays lui est de nous
permettre d'accéder à ce lieu là et j'en
profite je profite de votre micro je
sais que vous êtes lié par le temps mais
bernard il est grand temps il est grand
temps que la communauté musulmane c'est
plus de 3000 familles sur les deux
villes et quand vous multipliez par le
nombre d'enfants et de personnes qui
vivent dans ces familles là c'est
énormément de personnes qui sont
concernées et donc à plus de 90%
français ce sont des france il est
nécessaire de créer cette mosquée y en a
une sur trappe
freda licence par la communauté c'est
pas que ça ne concerne pas notre
communauté puisque là une mosquée par
définition c'est la maison de dieu et
donc elle est ouverte à tout le monde
mais c'est que nous nous vivons sur
cette communauté là nous vivons sur ces
deux villes
au lieu d'aller forcément aller sur
trappe et ailleurs ce que certains
d'entre nous font aujourd'hui mais à
leur grand désarroi
pourquoi il n'y aurait pas un lieu de
culte comme il y à des lieux de culte
juifs et catholiques et chrétiens sur
ces deux villages le signal donc ce
n'est pas une revendication par rapport
à ces religions là c'est une
revendication par rapport à une réalité
socio-économique sait que les immigrés
est en venu nous sommes à la deuxième
génération se sont dits français
maintenant ce sont des gens qui vivent
ici qui mourront ici qui n'ont pas
l'intention d'aller ailleurs
et donc ce serait dommage qu'ils ne
puissent pas eux qui quand il faudra le
faire du sport ou un gymnase sur leur
ville
et quand ils veulent aller au théâtre en
théâtre dans leur ville quand ils
veulent aller au marché en marché dans
leur ville mais quand ils veulent
pratiquer leur religion aujourd'hui non
mais là non vous devez y est allé dans
une autre ville ce serait quand même
dommage
l'état est laïc ceci dit pas ce que vous
comparez les gymnases les théâtres la
capture faciale juste façon de dire que
quand on est maire et qu'on prend en
considération des préoccupations de ses
concitoyens
je pense qu'à un moment ou un autre il
faut en parler avec l'air sympathique
et avec leur sarkozy il y avait une
espèce de de frémissement qui avait
commencé à être fait puisque monsieur
sarkozy avait donné des directives par
rapport à ces mairies et ces préfectures
là pour faciliter l'édification des
lieux de culte pour la communauté mais
vous aimeriez qu'aujourd'hui ça puisse
voir le jour 2 aimerions que vous passez
à ce que nous en avons assez de prier
dans des caves ou dans des appartements
qui ne sont pas pour ça et c'est le
message que vous passerez demain
représentants des deux municipalités que
vous avez convient l'étude les jeunes
aviateurs la lumière comme je vis de
toute l'agglomération saint-quentinoise
à venir partager cette fête avec nous ou
que ce soit c'est à dire que vous avez
des associations un peu partout qui vont
célébrer la fête de mayorat la prière de
la fête et on partagera un t1 cateau
j'invite tout le monde à venir partager
croyants non croyants musulmans non
musulmans tous c'est un moment de fête
ce sera la fête pour tout le monde
inch'allah merci de cette invitation et
merci de votre passage sur ce plateau de
tv fil 78 analyse non quelques minutes
on va donc parler de la chronique échos
du jeudi avec en invité bertrand de
créer le président du medef 78 un peu de
sport auparavant vous appréciez football
jeunes c'est la vie et savez vous qu'il
ya un club local qui crée la sensation
depuis le début de l'année le football
olympique plaisir roi et qui a déjà
sorti de la coupe gambardella une équipe
qui évolue et trois divisions au-dessus
d'elle le club pourrait remettre ça dès
ce week end c'est un johan jégou
concentrés et qu'ils regardent ces
joueurs se préparent l entraîneur des
u19 du football olympique plaisir roi
prépare le déplacement de dimanche à
saint leu la forêt pour le 4e tour de la
coupe gambardella après l'exploit du
mois dernier face aux ulis qui évolue
trois divisions au-dessus les yvelinois
veulent poursuivre l'aventuré
l'équipe valdoisienne est loin de les
impressionner elle qui évolue pourtant
deux niveaux plus hauts en division
d'honneur régionale
c'est qu'on n'est pas favoris donc on
prépare comme les autres matches et puis
le bas après on verra c'est un feeling
d'accord la gambardella c'est comme ça
quand vous dit chez nous réattaquer on a
l'appui sans lui ganic d'habitude parce
qu'on joue contre des grosses équipes
donc on essaye toujours de donner plus
donc c'est ça qui fait la diff
côté tactique pas de changement
l'entraîneur ne veut pas revoir la
recette qui a fait son succès on va
garder regarder en gros les schémas
qu'on a déjà mis en place depuis le
début de saison qu'ils ont plutôt bien
fonctionné plutôt un bloc défensif bas
en essayant d'aller jouer d'aller jouer
le contre ce sera certainement la
solution la solution pour battre une
équipe une équipe qui joue active de
division de chez nous donc on pense se
mettre en place de cette manière là
reste tout de même à oublier le faux pas
lors de la dernière journée de
championnat pour sa première défaite de
l'année l'olympique plaisir voix
s'étaient inclinés 4 à 0 le 4 0 je crois
que ça nous a remis ça nous a remis dans
le bain moussant était encore un peu sur
un nuage après la ds est on n'avait pas
on n'a pas encore fait des fêtes
jusqu'au depuis le début de championnat
donc le 4 0 ça peut le faire quelle du
maire c'est mauvais on a perdu mais moi
ça peut nous faire que du bien au niveau
au niveau mental coup d'envoi du 4e tour
de la gambardella dimanche 14h30 sur le
terrain de saint leu